this is your first movie Molly's game
that you directed yeah and I was curious
I know that obviously other directors
have done a beautiful job getting your
words onto the screen
did you have any struggles because you
can write some really good you right
fantastic dialogue but you get a lot of
words into a short space yeah did you
find as a director that it was hard to
direct someone speaking your words your
scripts on the third or fourth day of
shooting I called David Fincher who had
directed the social network and had been
kind of my Yoda on this and I said David
where did you tell the actors to breathe
when you're doing this and this is the
sound that I heard on the other end of
the phone that was all the help I got
from Dave yeah yeah like this is your
now you get to try that yeah yeah Maui's
game about Molly blooms exclusive yes
glad she brought it up Molly's game it
do you mind if I take what as well
that's what I was team me up for that
right yes I was seeing you man you can
tell you just directed wait no don't ask
okay yes I was asking you about Molly's
game take it away thank you
Molly's game is the true story 100% true
story of Molly bloom uh who when she was
in her 20s and 30s she ran the world's
most exclusive high-stakes poker game
billionaire hedge fund managers movie
stars star athletes politicians they
would win or lose millions of dollars in
the course of a night sometimes in the
course of a hand and it was all legal
until it wasn't until she crossed a very
thin line in the law and even that
didn't make a difference her downfall
was when she unknowingly inadvertently
invited several members of the Russian
mafia to play at hurricane yeah and
that's when the FBI got interested in
her in a hurry but it's it's really a
fantastic story about a fantastic woman
you don't need to know anything about
poker or care about poker at all I
watched it I watched it last night and I
know nothing about poker I'm a Hungry
Hungry Hippos man that's my limo I was
watching I was watching the movie and
totally just kept thinking this can't be
real this can't be real
and everything is 100% yeah
you